[Música]
bueno para contestar tu pregunta
mi niñez
fue una niña espectacular
tengo unos padres que me han apoyado
durante toda mi vida
luís soto y en quiñones siempre gozado
de una unión familiar espectacular junto
a mis hermanas hoy en día pues con mis
cuñados mis sobrinos y mi niñez fue
especial porque gracias a dios y a
diferencia de otras personas pues lo
tuve todo tuve todo lo que estaba al
alcance de mi papá para podernos dar a
nosotros siempre lo tuvimos ahí y no
tengo ninguna queja de lo que haya sido
mi niñez mi infancia es una etapa de mi
vida muy linda que la recuerdo
constantemente con mucho amor y cariño
cuando decidí convertirme en un drag
queen o un transformista
como la gente me conoce en una reina de
la noche pues mira fue algo inesperado
normalmente yo frecuentaba lugares para
ver espectáculos de compañeros artistas
transformistas drag queen pero nunca me
había interesado formar parte de lo que
era esta especie de espectáculo entonces
por casualidad un amigo mío tenía que
hacer una presentación y le canceló uno
de sus invitados él se vio en este
estrés de que no tenía un invitado y me
invita
a formar parte de su show yo le dije que
no
de primeras intenciones que no que no me
llamaba la atención tres palmas una
tarima él me dijo tú trabajas teatro tú
bailas
porque no no lo haces ayúdame y decidí
hacerlo esa noche eso fue en 1997 98 por
ahí aproximadamente y resultó ser que
cuando me bajé esa noche de la tarima el
dueño del club quedó tan encantado con
mi trabajo que no hice más que bajarme y
me dio trabajo por el próximo fin de
semana y como no tenía nada porque era
un principiante me entregó dinero y me
dijo esto es lo que hay necesito tu
presencia necesito tu show te quiero y
ahí comenzó toda esta aventura no fue
algo planificado fue como que ese esa
falta de que no había un invitado
disponible
jolie en ese espacio y ahí quedé y ya
son 24 años
yo siempre contaba con el apoyo de mi
familia ellos siempre han estado
presente en mi vida y al sol de hoy
son mi fan número uno ellos apoyan tanto
mis trabajos como el teatro los trabajos
que he hecho en televisión y obviamente
en las barras
y siempre contaba con el apoyo de ellos
y nunca ha habido una crítica ni un sí
ni un no porque mi trabajo se hace con
mucho respeto y ellos saben que yo
respeto al público esos son mis fans
número uno mi familia es súper especial
mira para mí el teatro ha sido súper
importante y la actuación claro está por
qué
hoy por hoy haber estudiado teatro haber
estudiado actuación es lo que me ayuda
noche tras noche poder tener estás
y poder interactuar con el público
todo el mundo sabe que el público no es
igual son públicos diferentes todas las
noches incluso en una noche pueden haber
muchísimas personas pero no todos son
iguales y gracias a lo que es el teatro
gracias adiós a lo que es la actuación
actuación pues me ha permitido poder
poder interactuar y desarrollarme más
para poder llegar al público tanto en la
comedia que es lo que yo me baso como
cuando voy llevando mensajes especiales
tanto sea de protección de
del cáncer de enfermedades que me ayuda
a poder desenvolverme para poder llegar
al público y llevar ese mensaje que yo
quiero mi nombre artístico es decir pero
a mi verdadero nombre es decir cuando yo
estaba en la escuela utilizaban mi
nombre para hacerme bullying porque el
nombre tiene una connotación un poco
femenina y me decían ay bien es decir
ahí viene la decir y al principio para
mí eso fue como algo bien hiriente me
afectó en cierto momento aprendí a
sobrellevarlo lo que era ese ese pequeño
bullying que me hacen en la escuela pero
le doy gracias a esas personas porque de
lo malo siempre surgen cosas buenas tú
tienes que aprender en la vida a
utilizar lo que te pasa negativo y
convertirlo en algo positivo en una
enseñanza y a mí me dio la oportunidad
de utilizar ese sobrenombre que ellos en
algún momento me hicieron sentir mal
el famoso decir que hoy en día como dije
anteriormente ya son 24 años
dándole vida a decir porque el nombre
que en un momento dado me afectó hoy en
día me da esta popularidad dentro del
público y a lo malo le saca algo bueno
así que yo lo único que le puedo decir a
las personas que sufren de bullying que
tratan de seguir a salir hacia adelante
que que no dejen que eso negativo le
afecte que pueda dominar su corazón y su
mente siempre tienen que agarrar como ya
le dije lo negativo y convertirlo en
positivo el tema que voy a estar
realizando verdad en este evento fue un
tema escrito por la cantante y
compositora lis y estrella de moca para
el mundo
fue creado en el 2015
cuando en puerto rico
surge la muerte de
una persona de la comunidad trans y ella
se inspiró en este suceso que la llenó
de coraje de impotencia y quiso hacer
esta canción para poder llevar un
mensaje para que la gente supiese cómo
nos sentimos nosotros en ese momento de
rechazo que viene obviamente tanto de la
comunidad heterosexual como de la
comunidad lg petete porque hoy en día
vivimos rechazos tanto de ambas
comunidades la canción tiene una letra
muy profunda y es como como un grito de
dvd estoy aquí mírame yo soy así no me
vas a cambiar lo que tú dices no no no
me hieren o no aunque me hiera
voy a salir hacia adelante como te dije
en un momento dado lo negativo se
convierte en positivo y esto es como un
grito de estoy aquí el título de la
canción es ponte en mi lugar nada más
con eso ya sabemos que es fuerte porque
en la letrada te está pidiendo que te
pongas en el lugar de esa persona que
está sufriendo este rechazo este
discrimen y ella decidió pues utilizar
este título para este tema que es muy
profundo que es muy rico y que se va a
presentar por primera vez en este evento
el tema y el arreglo que fue por dj
remix una persona muy querida dentro de
la comunidad del gp tt en puerto rico
sobre todo en el área oeste y obviamente
de las personas que trabajan y comparten
conmigo donde yo estoy todos los viernes
trabajando que es en el restaurant no
vale y en puerto rico en mayagüez
y es la primera vez que se va a
presentar este número
en estas plataformas todavía no se ha
hecho en discotecas no se ha hecho en
restaurantes y yo espero que les guste
que sea de su agrado y que lo compartan
compartan el tema es muy lindo y lizzy
estrella lo hizo con mucho amor para
toda la comunidad en gp y para toda esa
comunidad heterosexual que siempre nos
ha apoyado
[Música]
ponte en mi luz ponte mi luz ponte mi
luz y dime tú qué harías cuando un cura
bar o porque a mirar el rechazo este
nada va a cambiar mi forma de vida
no soy un error tengo un corazón que
cansado es
[Música]
por eso quiero tiene razón
no fue el dios
ponce me ponen mi nuca
y dime tú qué harías cuando un amor
tengas que esconder toda tu pasión por
el que digas
por tu familia siempre hablan porque
para señalar mi forma de ser
[Música]
quien hace como que no me conoce
cuando necesite
ponte en mi lugar
el milímetro
[Música]